you have to create the narrative you
have to have the imagination the fantasy
and I think the enthusiasm to do
something I am Annabelle sorf I'm
principal of sorf Architects we are at
the Martha Washington hotel located in
New York City
it became a very famous place for many
many years being an all women Hotel it
was celebrated as a safe place for women
to come and
stay we wanted to think that when you
enter the building that it wasn't
complete Discord with the exterior and
with the history of the building it's
also a modern welcoming informal space
in some ways but if you're so inclined
and you just want to come and have a
pizza you turn left and you find the
restaurant we always felt that this was
a kind of signifier for the restaurant
to have these really beautiful ovens
there is the food counter where you can
watch the chefs preparing pizzas and
other things or you sit in the grand
room and get served I never think about
did somebody else do the same thing or
is this already existing I much more
think about we're going to come back
here in 10 years and still love
it